Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week on
Orphan Black it's all about blowing shit up.
Mrs S and Sarah divide and conquer and Vic
the Dick gets molested by elves. Not really,
but we get to see some amazing Tatiana Maslany
acting as Sarah acting as another clone. We
also got to meet Michelle Forbes. She's playing
Rachel's boss at the Dyad.
If you're finding me for the first time I
try to do Orphan Black videos every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. I'm
down about two episodes just because I was
out of town but there's links to the full
playlist in the description.
So let's talk about how crazy things are getting.
Careful for spoilers in case you haven't seen
the episode. Here's my top 5 wtf moments,
then I'll do my review. Number 5 - Vic the
Dick gets molested by elves.
We need a book of Felix quotes. I think of
him as the punch up guy. Like when Allison
and Sarah just get way to heavy he just pokes
his head into frame and says something crazy.
Vic was totally a dick though. He deserved
everything that happened to him. The whole
Vic Sarah shitstorm wasn't quite as funny
as I expected it to be. Just painfully awkward.
I was surprised to find out that the police
officer he was talking to was the same one
who tried to get information out of Allison
in the parking lot a couple of episodes ago.
Number 4 - Sarah Pretends To Be Allison
I always love watching Tatiana do clones acting
as other clones. I don't know why she hasn't
won an emmy for it yet. The minute she started
dropping Monitor bombs on Donnie during their
role playing session I knew he was going to
figure everything out soon. To be fair Allison
had to explain it to him, but we finally get
a peek inside Donnie's head.
I actually expected him to be like any other
monitor but turns out Leekie was playing him
for the fool the whole time. It is kind of
sweet to think that he was being genuine the
whole time. He just thought it was some low
grade social experiment. That kind of explains
why he's so terrible at the spy stuff.
I think all of this means there's a good chance
he could wind up switching sides so to speak
and helping Clone Club before the end of the
season. He's like the loveable goofball of
the show, so that's why that surprise at the
end was so shocking. I'll talk about that
in a sec.
Number 3 - Rachel Confronts Doctor Leekie
Mrs S and Sarah blow their shit up. It worked,
not quite as expected and there was the added
twist of Rachel's boss Michelle Forbes, siding
with her over Leekie. They'd kind of teased
Leekie's side projects. Like the artificial
womb was just the tip of the iceberg. I'm
hoping they uncover more of his secret research
later in the season.
There is so much going on inside of Dyad right
now, it's like King's Landing in Game of Thrones.
They're all liars.
Rachel did defy Marion's wishes and let Leekie
go, which suggests that she might do something
to help the clones against Marion's wishes
before the finale. Michelle Forbes actually
did an interview about her character. She
teased that in the last two episodes of the
season Marion gets progressively weirder.
And she's the kind of person who's so powerful,
it doesn't even occur to her that subordinates
like Rachel would defy her.
She's really complex, but I see her more than
Rachel being the ultimate antagonist this
season. Don't be surprised if Rachel becomes
a stealth Clone Club member.
Number 2 - Kira Stem Cells
This was one of the few major violations in
the episode. In case you're confused. Leekie
and Delphine harvested Kira's stem cells from
a tooth she lost a long time ago. It's really
small, so there's not a lot. They used those
stem cells to treat Cosima, without her knowledge.
They totally worked, but that's not the issue.
Cosima is totally right to flip out. Delphine
almost seemed like a mad scientist during
their shouting match. But in the end she still
needs more of Kira's stem cells or she'll
die. Even the teaser for the next episode
shows her spitting up blood.
It seems like as we get closer to the finale,
events are conspiring to bring everyone back
together. Sarah is coming back with Kira nd
Donnie and Allison start discussing the Dyad
experiment.
I can't wait to see how Michelle Forbes character
pulls the strings to get them all to dance.
Number 1 - Donnie Kills Doctor Leekie
I love how casually this scene started out.
Leekie doesn't even care to give Donnie the
time of day, he's a speck of dust in the grand
design. But all it takes is one random encounter
to blow everything up. In this case, literally
Leekie's head.
It is confirmed, unless there is a Leekie
Clone floating around somewhere, he's gone
for good. But his influence will still inform
some really important things. That artificial
womb he was talking about. That's probably
going to have something to do with Cosima
getting better. That camera footage during
her operation was from inside her womb. She's
full of cancer, that's what the stem cells
are treating.
But I'm really interested to see if Cosima
and Delphine hijack Leekie's secret projects
to help solve the problem.
But now it's your turn, let me know what your
favorite moment was? Donnie Killing Leekie,
Sarah's Speech as Allison or Vic the Dick?
Overall I gave the episode a B plus. As complex
as the show already is, I feel like they're
doing a great job of escalating everything.
I was bummed we didn't catch up with Helena
this week, but I don't expect them to be able
to fit everyone into every episode.
Leekie as a character is irreplaceable. But
I think the show is trading the Mad Scientist
for The Smoking Man. Right now I think of
Michelle Forbes' character as being like the
Smoking Man from X-Files. Controlling everything
from a distance and totally ruthless in sticking
to an ominous plan.
Michelle Forbes is a neolutionist, so obviously
her goal is to patent human beings eventually.
As opposed to the Proletheans that just want
to homogenize the world.
One of my favorite things about the show and
something this episode did really well was
give characters a very grand send off. Like
the producers say, we're going to kill you.
But it's going to be amazing.
Donnie sounds like he's on the run in the
next episode, but I think he's going to end
up turning to Clone Club for help. I'm very
hopeful for his character. The only alternative
is for the Dyad to hunt him down. Either they
will or Sarah will send Helena after him.
The thing I'm looking forward to most right
now is learning more about the Marion character
and seeing what happens when Sarah turns herself
and Kira into the Dyad. I'm also kind of wondering
what Rachel is going to do with Duncan, eventually
they have to meet.
So I'll be posting my next Orphan Black episode
next week after episode 8. Be sure to subscribe
to get it. Also, if you have questions about
episode 6, the one I missed while I was away.
Just leave them in the comments.
Right now click here for my last Orphan Black
video and click here for my Maleficent Review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow
for fire and blood. High Fives!